hey everybody welcome to planet coaster
college in this video I'm going to talk
about breaks I had quite a few requests
about different kinds of breaks and
figured why not just put them into one
big video it'll be a little bit unlike
my usual video since I won't be really
building much just generally showing off
how different kinds of breaks work and
there will be the very basic approach to
this video and the most important thing
that I want to mention and how I'm going
to divide this video as well is that
there are three types of breaks that
you're going to want to think about
there are the block breaks there are the
trim breaks and the other category which
I would put together as the regular
kinds of breaks which are the sort of
breaks that just slow down the coaster
but don't really do anything outside of
that and don't really have any special
function outside of that and these three
kinds of breaks even though they might
seem just about the same in the game
actually aren't interchangeable and they
have very specific functions that are
not only in a realistic sense something
that you're going to want to keep in
mind if you want to make realistic
coasters but also in the sense of planet
coaster itself and getting good stats on
your coasters they can actually make a
difference as well and you want to make
the choice of using the right breaks at
the right time and if we look at the
breaks which we have over here this
right here is a block break these are
trim breaks and this is a regular break
and you can't really see a difference
there's also not much of difference to
see over here the only clear thing is
that the block breaks have friction
wheels which I'll talk about in a second
so why are the different functions for
these kinds of breaks well in a nutshell
block breaks are supposed to be used to
divide the coaster track into different
kinds of blocks which is something
that's quite complicated we can actually
be boiled down to a very simple concept
which I'll talk about in a minute but it
basically means that block breaks can
stop the coaster and release the coaster
car later on to make sure that coasters
don't come too close to each other and
don't start colliding trim breaks on the
other hand are placed in the middle of
the track to just randomly slow down the
coaster at any given point and the
regular brakes which are pretty much
just all the rest would usually be best
used just at the end of your track when
the coaster still
a lot of speed and you're gonna slow it
down before it goes into the station or
at any other point where you have this
straight part of the track where you
want to slow down the coaster you're
just going to be using regular brakes
now first off I want to go into block
brakes a little bit more because you
can't really understand the way they
work without understanding how blocks
work in coasters basically coaster
tracks are divided into different blocks
which are separated by block brake
sections or a lifter which also counts
as a block and basically what it means
is that no coaster train is allowed to
be on the same block of track as any
other train just to prevent collisions
of trains so what you can see over here
is because we have the lift Hill here
there's some track where it goes down
into the loop here and comes back to the
block brake section over here this would
mean that this is basically one block
and until this block has been cleared by
the Train before it's the coaster car
coming off of the lift Hill
cannot actually enter the block yet and
this is something that we can actually
see with this car over here as it gets
into the block brakes here it's able to
go but it still has to stop for a little
bit because just when it's go when it's
going into the brake run here this car
hasn't quite cleared this block over
here it's just entering the book brakes
and it really has to be cleared before
this car can enter this same kind of
block and usually you want to make sure
that cars don't actually have to wait on
the book sections block sections are
able to stop the train and keep it
moving again if it's really necessary to
hold the train if something if there's
some delay in the station or something's
holding up the other trains basically
but usually the best causes are the
courses that run perfectly without
having to stop any train at any point in
the track this goes for real life just
as in planet coaster if you wanna if
you're gonna hold down the cars for too
long on any block section or on the lift
Hill you're going to lose that in your
statistics and you're going to get a
lower excitement rating and the best way
to prevent this from happening is to
keep the blocks in somewhat similar
lengths so as you can see over here this
is a very short block where
goes into the looping and after that
goes straight into the block brakes but
after that there's this much longer
block where it goes through this barrel
roll very slowly into helix into another
curve and finally goes into the block
brakes so what you see is that this last
section actually takes quite a bit
longer than the first block and because
of that sometimes the car doesn't
actually clear the block before the next
car wants to come onto the block and as
a result it's going to have to wait on
the block brake section for a little bit
now what I also want to say is that in
planet coaster you can actually just
make your station super long to add
multiple trains onto your coaster but in
almost every case in real life block
sections are used to allow multiple
trains onto the same coaster so
realistically block sections are the
only way to get coasters with multiple
trains on them for most types and so
it's really something that I would
suggest doing and while this is a type
where you can see a lot of breaks in the
mid can sometimes be hard to know how
and when to place block brakes as that's
something that I want to go into right
now so here we have a coaster that's a
disaster not necessarily because I made
it but because it only has block
sections at the very end of the track
this one here is the block break section
we also have the lift Hill which means
that we do have enough blocks on the
coaster to actually allow two trains as
a standard rule of thumb you're going to
need one more block section than the
amount of trains that you have so three
blocks means that you're allowed to have
two trains on the coaster four blocks
means three trains on the coaster etc
now the problem here is that the entire
coast the layout is one big block
because it only gets into the first
block section at the very end of the
track here which means that this train
and this is something that you've
probably had before if you've just gone
into working with block sections this
train is going to wait for this entire
ride before it can actually come down so
it's going to wait for almost the
minutes at the top of the lift hill and
that is something that you can actually
quite easily prevent and with which you
can not only make the coaster more
realistic more fun and just generally
better but also a way in which you can
make the stats of the coaster better
so here we have an example of how it
should be done right here we have what's
called a mid-course brake run and this
is something which is very often used to
slow down the speed of the coaster in
the middle of the of the course
generally that's what the name stands
for but it's also most of the times a
blog section which allows you to split
up the coaster track into multiple
blocks so what we have over here is the
second train coming up and it's going to
want to enter this block but since the
block is actually quite small it only
runs from the left hill until the
mid-course brake run over here the first
train actually clears the first block
before this thing enters the top of the
litter which means that it's not going
to have to wait for any second it can
just roll straight out of the little and
that is basically what we're looking for
here now the next thing that I want to
talk about a little bit more in depth on
the trim brakes now these brakes are
pretty special because they can go into
any direction so if you take the regular
block brakes you can only go up and down
with them you have to have a track which
is straight not only as in the curves
but also when it comes to the banking
the same goes to the friction brakes
which are more or less the regular
brakes and some courses these will be
magnetic brakes but this is why I would
put anything that's not either trim or
block brakes in the same category
because they basically do the same thing
but when it comes to the trim brakes you
can actually go into any direction that
you want you can actually do weird
curving inversions and anything that you
really like to do that you can do with
the coaster you can pretty much do with
trim brakes so the question is why not
just use trim brakes everywhere instead
of the regular brakes well from a
realistic standpoint
that's because trim brakes are are only
meant to trim the speed of the coaster
and not to really slow it down to the
exact speed where it can roll into the
station or a brake run and also trim
brakes don't have the functionality of a
blog section since you obviously can't
have the coaster hanging on the top of
this hill whenever the coaster behind it
or in front of it hasn't finished its
block and then just have the coaster go
on so trim brakes can really only be
used to slow down the speed of the
coaster a little bit which is also why
they are able to twist and turn into any
direction that the track
is able to go into because that's pretty
much their function they're placed on
the middle of the track you don't even
need a straight piece of track they can
just be placed inside a curve inside a
hill or whatever place you need to trim
the speed of the coaster a little bit
with they are usually placed in real
life for maintenance reasons or for
money reasons sometimes they are put
into the design of the coaster and this
is definitely something that you can do
as well for instance if somehow the the
second part of your layouts it the
coaster goes through it too fast the
forces are too high on it there's too
much fear and nausea ratings you can
actually slow it down without having to
go back into the track and add a
straight break run because you can just
add some trim breaks somewhere to slow
down the coaster a little bit which is
also the way that it's done in real life
very often but what you what these
things are actually most infamous for
especially among coaster enthusiasts is
being added after the coaster is already
built because whenever coasters go
faster than expected or just fast in
general it wears the track down quicker
so these things are sometimes put onto
coasters to make sure that the coaster
is a bit slower and is actually cheaper
to maintain and doesn't run into as many
issues it can also definitely be for
safety issues but they're generally very
unpopular with coaster enthusiasts
because they tend to take a lot of the
fun out of coasters simply because they
take out a lot of the speed of the
coasters so yeah I wouldn't say that
these things are the most fun thing to
add only really add them when they're
necessary or when they're really a
realistic addition to a coaster for
instance some coaster types like bnm
hyper coasters which is the type that
this one is are actually pretty infamous
for very often using a lot of trim
brakes now for one of these in action
I am tuning to the same coaster that I
built earlier on and I put a small trim
break over here because it felt like the
second part of the layout was just too
fast and it was going over these hills
and a little bit too much of a speed you
can also tell that this has been my
error in making this layout it's because
it suddenly becomes a lot
our after the drop after the Midcoast
break one over here so this seemed like
a pretty good little spot to add some
trail mix to make sure that it hops over
these final hills and a bit more of a
manageable speed now if we compare the
coasters based on the block breaks and
the train breaks we can actually see
that the one that's completely broken
and has to stop at the top of the lift
Hill has the worst excitement rating by
far this version has the Midcoast brake
run and the trim breaks at the end and
has a much lower much higher excitement
rating at six point four also made a
clone of the coaster with a mid-course
brake run and the trim breaks and remove
the trim breaks which actually made the
excitement rating higher but also make
the fare higher so here you can see that
it does add more excitement to the
coaster to actually have no trim breaks
but if you want to make your ride more
family-friendly or if you're really
going to pull some harsh g-forces if
there aren't any trim breaks you can
bring down the fear rating and perhaps
also the nausea rating if you've got
some crazy curves going on of a coaster
by adding the trim breaks so it's really
just sort of weighing the very options I
would say there is no very easy surefire
way to get this right all the time it
does take a bit of experimentation like
adding the trim breaks or adding the
block section does it make the coastal
better or notes it really just depends
on the context but generally this is how
you use both types and how you can use
them to actually get some better
coasters more realistic coasters and
perhaps if you're looking for that some
better ratings of your coasters in the
game as well the biggest mistake here is
not making sure that the coaster doesn't
stall at any point in the write because
that'll cost you many of the stats even
if the rest of the ride is completely
the same having those moments where it
does completely nothing is just going to
ruin your stats now as for the last type
of breaks I already talked a bit about
this but these are any of the breaks
that aren't remakes or block breaks and
the one thing to just keep in mind is
that there's the most simple to use they
just slow down the coaster they are
usually put in front of the station or
where you really want the coaster to
slow down a lot so you could put these
in front of book breaks to come
break it a bit already and the one thing
that you really want to know about these
before building them is that
realistically they should be put up on a
bit of an incline because even though
the block breaks have these friction
wheels that can keep the coaster running
on this very straight piece of track the
drill the regular brakes don't actually
have this so they need to be able to
release the brakes and still have the
coaster go forward at least a little bit
by itself anyway that's it for this
video it's been a little bit on
orchestrated and a bit longer than I
figured beforehand as well but I hope
it's useful in some way and if you have
any questions or feedback still afraid
to leave it in the comments and I'll see
you in the next video